sport automobile on va se bousculer sur
les pistes d'afrique en janvier prochain
après le rallye 5,5 transafrica le paris
dakar va quitter la capitale le 1er
janvier de nombreux équipages régionaux
seront au départ avec une belle soif
d'aventuré tout de suite un reportage de
dennis ferrer sur ce rallye paris dakar
départ le 1er janvier prochain
quelque part dans l'île de chatou
quelques-uns des nombreux citadins qui
vont chercher laventure sur les routes
et les pistes du prochain paris dakar
début janvier effectué les dernières
mises au point de leur véhicule auto
moto avant d'affronter la dure réalité
africaine
la deuxième édition de ce rallye va
réunir plus de 200 concurrents
ce sera le trion des engins à quatre
roues motrices qui trouveront un espace
et liberté pour exprimer toute leur
possibilités mais au fait qu'est-ce qui
fait courir tous ces équipages des
villes vers les chemins de latérite
rouge
pour répondre à un besoin personnel de
d'emmener avec moi derrière moi ils ont
maintenant on peut le dire une masse de
gens qui ont besoin de connaître cette
aventure que nous offre l'afrique sur ce
terrain un merveilleux est tout à fait
pour destiné à une telle course et je
veux dire que cet attachement à
l'afrique
bon pour certains se compose de voyages
de tourisme pour nous c'est de la course
la course intense la course absolue avec
la découverte avant tout soi-même car
l'afrique est un grand révélateur de
personnalité mais ne s'improvise pas
africains qui veulent aventure a des
limites que certains auraient tendance à
dépasser c'est pourquoi la sélection et
la sécurité des participants ont fait
l'objet de soins particuliers par les
organisateurs nous avons été extrêmement
serrée sur ce sur ce point de vue car
l'an passé nous avons laissé jusqu'à
dernière minute s'engager des gens qui
partaient et dans 7 ans était prof dans
cette course vraiment comme sur une
promenade touristique
ce n'est pas le cas il ya une chose que
l'on peut faire pour personne c'est
raisons psychologiques c'est à dire est
ton ou mettons pas capable de partir en
afrique et traverser le dr seul pour les
gens qu'ils font en moto ou même à 2 la
promiscuité quand même quelque chose
d'important aussi ma par contre sur le
plan physique qui a nous conseillons
vivement à tous les gens qui nous pose
la question d'être parfaitement au point
maintenant c'est une course qui n'est
pas véritablement une course de qui
n'est pas souvent pas un sprint mais qui
réclament par contre beaucoup
d'endurance est une course qui use ça
use les hommes c'est ce genr ça use
aussi bien sur les mécaniques
donc c'est un condensé de
de ces trois choses qu'il faut arriver à
équilibrer mais quel but recherche tous
ceux qui partent et dans quel esprit
partie civile s'est recréé sur terre ce
qui existe sur la mer c'est à dire faire
une transat mécanique sur sur mer de
sable et de créer sur le sur terre en
fête des hommes qui iront rejoindre dans
la légende de l'eswc est au moins les
grands marins et faire en sorte que
l'automobile a fait souvent la mécanique
en général le soit plus synonyme de
problème et de soucis mais synonyme
d'oxygène justement et d' aventure